này gì không
vẫn
là một người đã xem đi mất rồi không sao
đôi khi thường là video của tôi thường
là đa số là m không xem lại thường tôi
thấy là
thế Thực ra lâu lắm không để ý lượt xem
luôn đây tôi vào đánh giá
xem
xem Ừa xem cũng không còn gọi là nhiều
cho lắm Ờ nếu mà trong web bán hàng Ồ
trong web bán hàng có vẻ là lượt xem cao
hơn Còn nếu mà
tâm sự thì có vẻ
là ít hơn khá nhiều
là lượt xem trực tiếp ấy thì lại
cao còn lượt xem kiểu lượt xem lại này
có vẻ không cao này thì chắc là chắc là
kiểu nó sẽ thu hút những cái bạn mà à
kiểu thấy ở xem chứ còn nhưng mà đa số
của kênh của tôi chắc là dành cho những
bạn à Kiểu theo ngành IT này thì chắc là
người ta muốn xem về kiến thức Nhưng mà
mấy người đấy lại ít on để xem trực tiếp
tôi thấy là thế vì à Thấy lượt xem của
mấy cái video gọi nhỉ Những người những
người xem trực
tiếp của cái mấy cái buổi mà làm bài tập
thì tôi thấy thưởng chỉ có dao động tầm
ba mấy hai mấy người đấy Kiểu thế còn
đội tương tác còn thấp hơn nữa nhưng
mà nhưng mà gì nhỉ
ờ lời xem lại của họ cao phết đ Tôi đánh
giá thấy có nhiều l Xem cao cho đây là
hôm nay rảnh hôm nay ngồi lướt lướt Xem
thế nhưng mà định hướng của kênh tôi như
tôi đã nói thì thực ra tôi sẽ chia sẻ
cho các bạn chủ yếu là mọi thứ có thể và
nó là cả góc nhìn của tôi nữa ừ nên là
nó sẽ không phải dừng lại ở mỗi lập
trình Nói chung là cứ toàn bộ những cái
gì mà tôi cảm thấy hay ho và đặc biệt
đặc biệt đó là các bạn sẽ thấy nói chung
là tôi cũng là 27 tuổi rồi tôi cũng sẽ
nói chung là chia sẻ của một người không
phải là một người từng trải lắm mà là
một người kiểu đang trưởng thành đang
kiểu đang cố hòa nhập hòa đồng để mà
kiểu
à gọi là hòa nhập với xã hội à Gọi gì
nhỉ nó kiểu dạng cố thích nghi được với
cái xã hội hiện tại với kiểu dạng này
tức cách là một một người đang chưa có
gì cả thì nó sẽ như thế nào nên là góc
nhìn của tôi nó chắc chắn là nó sẽ
Ồ nó sẽ chưa hoàn thiện nhưng mà nó sẽ
kiểu dần dần dần các ông sẽ thấy là tôi
sẽ trưởng thành dần hơn cách nói chuyện
mọi thứ nó sẽ ổn hơn cũng như là
à Cái quan trọng nhất ấy Cái quan trọng
nhất ấy là tôi thấy cái gì hay tôi sẽ
chia sẻ một cách rất là thắng thắn và
thành thật chứ không phải là kiểu có ngụ
ý theo kiểu là lùa gà này hay là
kiểu cái gì hay giữ cho mình xong rồi
mình kiểu V dụ dỗ người khác vào con
đường gì gì đó để cho gọi là nhở vu Lợi
bản thân thì thì ít nhất là tôi không
như thế đấy nên là tôi nghĩ là tôi được
cái sẽ chân thành thôi có nhiều kênh chứ
có rất nhiều kênh giỏi rất nhiều người
thành công rồi tôi rất theo dõi rất
nhiều kênh kiểu thế thì tính ra mình
không thể hơn được những cái kênh
đấy tất cả về mọi mặt luôn kể cả việc
giọng nói hay không hản hơn này chuyên
môn thì cũng không hơn này đến cả việc
ngồi làm sáng tạo nội dung này ngồi
chỉnh sửa video cũng không có này không
hiểu Ừ Phả tự hỏi ra mấy ông nghe kênh
tôi để làm gì rất nhiều kênh khác tốt
hơn đúng không thì chắc là được cái là
Tôi thành thật thật thà các thứ các thứ
tôi nghĩa là tôi có cái gì đấy Có cái
người ta gọi cái từ đấy là
từ cái gì nhở từ cái gì Point ấ nhở
kiểu điểm à điểm khác biệt ấy cái gì
điểm ăn tiền ấy Nó là cái gì po ấ tôi qu
mất rồi đợ hỏi chvt
gọi cái gì toi
ấy từ tiếng Anh chuyên ngành của nó Ừ
tôi được cái nhiệt tình ông không biết
đâu tôi vừa Ờ
tôi đầu tiên thì tôi thấy có vài bạn gần
đây có hỏi về kiểu không phải hỏi đâu Họ
đăng Story thôi Kiểu thế kiểu khoe đi
nhổ răng khôn hoặc là kiểu hỏi có chỗ
nhổ các thơ thứ tôi cho dù tôi người lạ
tôi cũng bình luận
vào bình kiểu à Tôi gợi ý cái chỗ mà tôi
từng nhổ hai cái răng khôn ở nhà tôi thì
thc ra tôi khoe ở đây mấy ông cũng được
nh kiểu là cho dù cho dù rõ ràng ở đấy
Vừa rồi tôi có ra tôi hỏi là tại sao họ
không Cái phòng khám này tương đối xịn
rất là nổi Cũng không phải rất là nổi mà
nói chung là rất là xịn ấy Tại sao lại
không quảng bá trên ít nhất là không có
trên google map đấy Xong rồi tiếp tân
người ta còn bảo là thực ra là bởi vì sợ
quá tải kiểu bây giờ cũng đông rồi ấy
không cần phải quảng cáo kểu thế quảng
cáo quá tải quá không kiểm soát được như
thế là lần đầu tiên thấy mấy ông có giờ
kiểu thế không kiểu mình mở ra nhưng mà
mình sợ Đông cuộc quá
thôi không có trên google map nhá chia
sẻ bạn bè thì kiểu bạn bè Lên tra tị
Google các thứ thứ như không ra thì tôi
có bảo là bên này đủ uy tín để không cần
phải kiểu chạy quảng cáo quảng cáo nó
mới lên trang đầu đúng không ạ thì bên
này không còn chạy quảng cáo gì cả thì
bạn tôi còn tạm tin một tí nhưng mà tra
trên Google Map C không có đấy Cái này
là phòng khám tư nhân kiểu của phó phó
giám đốc bệnh viện Dăm Hà mặc Trung ương
Hà Nội Mở tư nhân tại nhà đương nhiên là
cũng có đội ngũ mọi thứ rồi bao nhiêu
thứ nhưng mà đại khái thì tính ra nó vẫn
là nhà người ta nên thành ra kiểu nó chỉ
nó không nó gọi nhở nó bốn phòng thôi
tôi đến thì vừa rồi tôi đến thì cũng
thấy cũng có ba bốn người đang ngồi chờ
rồi đấy Nên là nói chung là có lý do tự
nhiên họ như thế Ừ nhưng mà cũng lần đầu
ông nghe kiu đấy đúng không kiểu ấy thì
tôi đại khái tôi nhiệt tình theo kiểu là
tôi qua đấy tôi chụp ảnh các thứ kiểu
phòng khám để kiểu check in hộ bạn kia
để bạn ấy biết là ở trong phòng khám uy
tín chứ không phải là mình kiểu và mình
đương nhiên mình chẳng được hoa hồng
mình chẳng được cái gì cả Mình đi chia
sẻ cái quán gọi là cho là quán ruột à
không đúng lắm đại khái thì TT còn hai
cái cần nhổ nữa Hồi đấy tôi có bốn cái
mọc lệch thì chuẩn là sẽ phải nhổ cả bốn
nhưng mà mới nhổ được hai thì lần đấy
tôi nhổ bác sĩ khá mắt tay và chính bác
sĩ để luôn Còn bây giờ thì hình như là
có thuê những bác sĩ khác cũng có chuyên
môn ở ngoài rồi thì hồi đấy nhổ mỗi một
cái thì là một củ hai cái hai củ Hồi đấy
khi mà tôi Hết thuốc tê ấy tối hôm đấy
Hết thuốc tê thì tôi chẳng cảm thấy gì
cả Nói chung mọi thứ rất là ổn nên tôi
cảm thấy kiểu tôi nói chung cái gì tôi
cảm thấy hay cảm thấy đủ thì tôi
sẽ gọi là chia sẻ chia sẻ cho mọi người
mỗi tội là tôi hơi nhiệt tình quá kiểu
như thế kiểu nhiều người
sẽ sẽ tưởng là kiểu mình đang mình đang
gì đó
ấy Thực ra là tính Tôi thích chia sẻ thế
thôi gọi như nào nhỉ Có rất nhiều người
là kiểu
ờ
rất nhiều không đúng lắm nhưng đại khái
nà kiểu Có rất có một vài người sẽ kiểu
có cái nhu cầu
là thích được cần ấy mấy bạn biết khái
niệm này không kiểu dạng là à Tôi thấy
tôi muốn người khác kiểu không hẳn muốn
người khác cần mình như đại khái là kiểu
muốn khác cảm thấy có thể tin tưởng được
mình ấy để làm làm được mọi chuyện không
phải tin tưởng đây là để mình lợi dụng
hay gì cả An chỉ em là cảm thấy mình
muốn là người tốt thôi muốn chia sẻ các
thứ các
thứ khó diễn Đản nhỉ nói chung đại khái
thì à Nó cũng có cái tên của bệnh tâm lý
đấy vân vân h trượng có
đọc bây giờ cái gì Chẳng nghĩ ra thành
tên một cái bệnh tâm lý đúng không Ngoài
thời gian học trên trường em vẫn như
thói quen quay lại kênh anh để học tiếp
Ồ cũng được thì anh bảo kênh của anh phù
hợp với kiểu lúc đầu nếu mà ông nào mà
kiểu theo dõi từ đầu đúng không thôi Đến
bây giờ là lộ trình cũng khá phù hợp để
mà V gọi là gọi là Junior một tí rồi đấy
thì học dần dần dần tiếp thì lại khá ổn
n đang nói là những có những bạn mới
hoặc hợp chí là những bạn senor rồi
chẳng hạn thì cũng chưa chắc là phù hợp
với thí kệnh kênh của
Project thế nào À hôm trước tôi mới chia
sẻ trên cái kênh discord của tôi hôm nay
có một bạn hỏi V hỏi à Hỏi trên discord
cho Tí tôi sẽ chia sẻ sao bên này nửa
che tên nửa không che nữa nhỉ bị lỗi
rồi username chă kết như vài người à Cái
này chắc là tên của họ chứ không phải
username
Ờ đây tôi có cái tài liệu này các
pro sinh viên nên thêm vào CV đấy Hợp lý
không đấy Cái này chắc là để tôi ghim
Thực ra là tôi định ghim lại nhưng mà
thực ra là trong này tôi thấy toàn cái
cũng khá là hay ấ nên là chuẩn là nếu mà
ghim phải ghim hết đấy Nói chung là ờ
trong này có nhiều cái Mà chư tôi ghim
vài cái ở đây này
nhá
Ờ dùng để đếm ngược thời gian Cuộc Đời
trên s á em để ý à cái này này cái này
là 4000 tuần anh định lấy cái hồi trước
của anh Tuấn từng chia sẻ phải cái đếm
ngược trông hay hơn cơ nhưng cái này
Thực ra cũng được Cũng được nhỉ h gần
hết ngày hôm nay rồi này gần hết tháng
rồi
này tầm mới tầm 1/4 của năm này và đi
được 36 ph cuộc đời rồi
u xà vãi
chư 36
ph thự như tôi lại nhớ quả bài hát
A 30 à 30 tuổi cái gì quên sư mới tên
bài hát
rồi hát g cái gì 30 nhỉ Anh đã đi 1/3
1/3 cuộc
đời gì đấy phải đúng rồi à quên vừa nãy
đang nói là cái gì nh
Không phải anh ạ đi 1/3 cuộc đời gì gì
đấy của Trịnh hang Bình Ấy À đúng rồi
tâm sự tuổi 30 Ok điểm
ăn khách à nổi bật so với đối
thủ gọi
là cái gì po không nhớ nhớ chờ
mạnh điểm vật trong tiếng Anh có thể gọi
là đây unic selling Point Đúng rồi Đúng
rồi
đấy một cái yếu tố kiểu ghi điểm nổi bật
so với đối thủ
đấy trong sắc tanh Hình như là có một từ
Kiểu cái gì s po à cái gì Kiểu unic po à
Nói chung đại khái nhớ có một từ của nó
ông ông
này cái bạn mà sang này hỏi tôi on chưa
alo
ờ chữa cái database thứ thứ à on d
này gọi mic không
Em gọi mid đi để cho mình tiện Hoặc là
nếu mà em không tiện gọi thì thôi Bây
giờ anh sẽ thử nói xong rồi xong rồi em
em nhắn tin cũng được anh anh sẽ thử hỏi
một vài câu xong rồi em nhắn tin hoặc là
nếu mà em cảm thấy là gọi được anh em
gọi thì mình gọi nói chuyện luôn càng
vui thỉ thoảng kiểu đấy giống kiểu gọi
như nà gọi phóng vấn Podcast à Ừ Ok
Ok Tôi có xin phép ông đấy là sẽ mở này
Ừ sáng nay mở bằng ma N không sao Bây
giờ mở bằng Windows hơi sợ m cái file
kiểu này dễ virus lắm nên mở không nhỉ
Bây giờ tôi lỡ không Chưa cài máy ảo
chung Đây máy mới hồi trước là có cài
máy ảo cơ xong rồi bây giờ phải vứt file
ở trong phần máy ảo đấy các thử thử chưa
gi mở như này Hôm nay thì không sao
nhưng mà về sau có mấy ông nà nó lừa tôi
cải các thử thử à Đằng nà mình đang bị
mất nick Face nhỉ Chắc máy này chảng có
cái gì
đâu sbx á Nhớ thằng này có sbx mà đúng
không sbox của cái Window hồi trước là
cái gì nhỉ Tôi nhớ là có một cái
từ tên của
nó
ừ
phát
ông này thì chắc không sao đâu nhưng mà
nói chung là cũng phải mở dần các thử
thứ đúng
ơi nhờ bâ gi phải reset cơ sĩ phải reset
thôi hôm hôm nay chắc không sao hôm nay
mở rồi để hôm sau reset không
khác chắc chắc là chắc là cái này chưa
phải file virus đâu còn hôm sau sẽ cẩn
thận nếu mấy ông cứ cẩn thận các thứ thứ
đúng không Thì đôi khi đôi khi là không
phải ông này đâu đôi khi là người khác
gửi ông này ông ấy tưởng nó đã file an
toàn rồi ông ấy gửi cho người khác Chia
sẻ u đúng không
Đấy chắc không sa đâu Ơ Thực ra là các
bạn biết vụ đấy Không là file pdf đuôi
file ch thì cho chả nó nguy hiểm cái thứ
thứ đúng không
đấy chứ còn pdf cũng cũng Hồi trước tôi
nhớ là cũng có cũng có vấn đề nói chung
là cứ cẩn thận thì vẫn hơn đúng không
chí là cả bấm vàoo mấy cái link lạ ở
trên trên kiểu mail chẳng hạn các th thứ
Ừ nhỉ tôi Thỉnh thoảng bấm nói chung là
mình cũng Nếu có thể vẫn nên cẩn thận
đây lập trình web Java đúng không Java
có thử thử bỏ qua này form đăng nhập các
thứ thứ để xem nào bạn đang thiết kế
database kiểu username password user
ex xem à cái này
năng buổi
[âm nhạc]
đầu tính năng hệ thống đăng nhập đăng K
tài khoản Hiển thị các kỳ thi có có nhắc
kỳ thi ok này lại tiếp tục lại ngồi vẽ
sơ đồ thôi ạ
ờ cứ vẽ ra mấy cái kiểu Thục thể các th
các thứ đúng
không
À mình đặt tên từ tế đi không Vì sao
không nhớ được Cái nào Cái nào đây là
ờ quản lý
à quản lý gì
đi anh chấp nhận thế
có người dùng các thứ thứ đúng không
tiny tôi có mở vmware rồi thì
thái có thể tru cập hoặc tru cập tự do ồ
nghĩa là đấy nghĩa là cái này nó liên
quan kỳ thi ok rồi tìm kiếm hoặc lọc kỳ
thi theo tên hoặc trạng thái rồi chọn
bài thi để bắt đầu làm nghĩa là có nhắc
đến bài thi ok bài thi
chat nhá trên discord anh không mở thông
báo ch không
câu
hỏi
rồi lựa chọn lựa chọn cho mỗi câu đấy
lựa chọn kiểu đáp án đúng không đáp án
là xử
thế bộ đếm thời gian n mỗi bài thi bài
thi sẽ có thêm
a thời
gian rồi
Ờ nộp bài để gửi bài thứ thứ thông báo
hết giờ rồi hiển thị số C trời đứng tổng
số câu tính toán và hiển thị điểm số xem
lại câu trả lời và đáp án đúng có thể
xem kết quả các thứ thứ Xem kết quả
đương nhiên là sẽ phải lưu lại kết quả
của của người của người làm đúng không
Nghĩa là người làm sẽ bình tĩnh bình
tĩnh bình tĩnh nhá bình tĩnh nhá Để tôi
hình dung đã đầu tiên có kỳ thi trước
này Người dùng bỏ qua này người dùng bao
gồm
cả một là tách ra là admin hoặc là gì gì
đói thường Nếu có thể thì tôi nghĩa tách
ra cũng được bởi vì người người thi nó
sẽ kiểu có lưu có thể nhiều thông tin
hơn so với người dùng bình thường
đấy Cái này là là người dùng người kiểu
người đăng nhập ấy người thi nó khác
người thi mình cần lưu th nhiều thông
tin hơn ví dụ người dùng admin thì cần
Phả lưu nhiều thông tin đến thế Đấy ông
ông hiểu gì tôi không ạ Đây là u user
kiểu dạng người
dùng dùng để đăng nhập ấy nó có kiểu
email password các thứ thứ và pro ấy
email này password này xong rồi pro này
chẳng hạn kiểu cấp độ các th các thứ ấ
đấy còn người chi thì sẽ lưu nhiều thông
tin kiểu kiểu mã sinh viên xong rồi Kiểu
nói chung các thông tin của người dùng
đúng không Ok đầu tiên là tạo bài thi
này một loạt câu hỏi này đáp án này thì
bao gồm đây sẽ phải là
có ngoài việc
là nội dung của đáp án đúng không sẽ còn
phải là thêm một cái là kiểu dạng là xem
nó đúng hay sai ấ Nếu n mà để tiếng Anh
thì tôi nghĩ nó sẽ là is
correct không phải is correct mà final
answer nó gọi là gì nhỉ tiếng Anh bây
giờ gì nh
chity thường dùng
conq thực cái này về database không hẳn
Liên Quan Đế lắm
xem Tôi muốn đặt tên một code đ kiểm tra
à đây trong
bả đáp
tên tiếng Anh là gì À thôi Đặt tên tiếng
Việt trước đi em Chắc là em muốn để toàn
bộ tiếng Anh database toàn bộ tiếng Anh
hay là như nào chỉ nên tự tin là dùng
tiếng Anh khi mà mình cũng gọi là biết
một chữ tiếng Anh
nhá Còn nếu mà giả sử mà mình cảm thấy
tiếng Anh Mình chưa đủ vững ấy nên để
hết tiếng Việt không về sau đương nhiên
là tiếng Anh này vẫn chỉ dừng ở mức cơ
bản thôi các bạn cũng đừng nên nghĩ một
cái từ gì đó khó quá khó quá thì chính
bản thân mình phải nhớ về sau các thứ
hoặc chính không phải bản thân mình mà
người làm cùng với mình chẳng hạn chẳng
nhớ được phát âm nó như nào không nhớ
được cách phát âm thì chắc chắn không
nhớ cách viết các thứ vân vân
đấy nh tiếng ngay
khá là chuẩn Bởi vì kiểu tiếng Việt
không dấu đi khi khó hiểu hơn đúng
is correct đấy Đúng rồi tôi tôi cũng
hiểu x correct các thứ
chốt luôn được correct
đấy đấy sẽ
là
sẽ có thêm chữ S đấy question này
đó
Đây cái này content à đúng nhở cứ hiểu
nội dung content nhá
Đấy question cũng là content
đấy mỗi câu này sẽ bao nhiêu điểm gì đó
Nếu giả sử ở đây không hề đề cập là một
câu bao nhiêu điểm chắc là câu nào cũng
như
nhau chắc
thế thời gian thì đây là
time thời gian làm
bài có gì em cứ hỏi hỏi chbt các thứ thứ
về kiểu đặt tên nó hợp lý nhá ví dụ C
Câu này sẽ là ờ thời gian thời gian cái
cột thời gian làm bài ở trong bảng bài
thi tiếng Anh nên để là gì
đấy đương nhiên vẫn chú trọng việc ngắn
gọn nhá cứ để anh thử ví dụ cho em nhá
cột thời gian
dấu ấ sợ nó khó hiểu trong bả bài thi
thời gian làm bài
đó là bợt giải thích CH cho tao đáp án
đúng rồi đúng rồi duration nghe hợp lý
lấy là kiểu nó là thời gian quá trình
các thứ th
được bà bài Khi tiếng Anh là
gì đấy à đâu Chắc là xem rồi nhỉ Ừ nghĩ
cao siêu quá hơi lạm dụng
quation
đó nhưng mà Đây mới chỉ dừng lại việc
tạo xong cái bài thi các thứ còn bây giờ
để mà thực sự là lưu lại là cái người
người đấy làm cái bài thi nói chung kết
quả như nào đúng không ạ thì việc một
người này tác động đến thằng này này nó
là một nhiều thì kiểu gì mình sẽ tạo
bảng trung gian này người dùng đấy trả
lời từng câu hỏi này như nào ở trung
gian này Đấy và cái thằng này nó sẽ chọn
đáp án gì Cá thứ thứ nó là trung gian
đấy thì thì cái mối quan hệ trung gian
trung gian này nó sẽ tạo ra một cái A Nó
là một nhiều Nhiều này nhiều Nhiều này
nhiều nhiều đúng không nó tạo ra cái
bảng ở đây tôi sẽ kiểu để dạng bảng đi
đấy dạng bảng
nhá Mấy cái đi mấy bỏ qua chứ ông bắt
tôi tên tất cả Cột rồi
á Không chỉ ghi những cái mà kiểu cần
gọi là mấy cái kiểu cần bắt buộc phải có
của mấy cái kểu từ cái yêu cầu
chứ chứ Đây đâu phải tất cả các cột đâu
đúng không ID chắc chắn phải có tất bảng
nào chẳng có cột ID nên là như thế đúng
không
đấy thì cái thực thể này và thực thể này
nó sẽ tạo ra một cái bảng trung gian
đúng không Đấy bảng này sẽ là kiểu Nếu
Là Anh đặt ấy thì để mà tiện đối với
larel thường là kiểu nó là bảng Private
mà bảng Trung Doan giữa hai thằng thường
là ví dụ đây
là người người tham gia thi gọi gì à B
bả người tham gia thi tiếng Anh là
gì xem thường là xamer à gì nhở h gọi gì
à
attendant attend à attend là kiểu
là
emly thôi cái trò student nó nhanh bị
phức tạp
nhở Chắc đây cũng chỉ là sinh viên mà
Đấy student và đây nếu
mà nếu mà cách đặt của của lel ấy priv
ấy trung gian đữa hai thằng này ấ nó sẽ
như th này nghe nó hơi tối nghĩa nhỉ
Đúng không nhỉ Có tối nghĩa lắm không
nhỉ XM
student mạ trung gian trung gian sẽ lưu
kiểu này nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ sắp xếp thằng
nó nằm trong bả chữ cái thằng nào đứng
trước thì đứng trước này kiểu như
này thứ tự bằng chữ
nhá nghĩ này xong trước mắt thì cứ ghi
đã thì ở đây lưu lại cái bảng này bảng
này Thực ra không sao Mình sẽ có ID để
nối sang cái bảng dưới này nữa
Tôi có khi đang nhầm đấy tế là một thằng
này tham một thằng này mình bình tĩnh
nhá Thằng này là thằng thằng này thằng
con thằng này đúng không đúng không cái
này ông rõ rồi đúng không Thằng này
thằng con thằng này
này CH qua chị nh À đây nghĩa là thằng
này phải lưu ID thằng này này đúng không
Thằng này phải lưu ID thằng này này
thì khi mà người dùng thằng này thì lại
phải lưu ID
của kỳ thi này này đây để Vứt cái này
sang bên này kỳ thi này
ấy Thực ra là sinh viên chỉ nối đến đây
thôi chứ nhỉ Nó là kiểu một sinh viên có
nhiều một sinh viên chọn nhiều Đáp án
thì chẩn nó chỉ n đến đây chị nhỉ xem
nào đây từ đây nó sẽ lấy được ID của
thằng này thằng này nếu mà làm theo kiểu
chuẩn hóa thì nó sẽ là như thế một sinh
viên có trả lời nhiều câu hỏi nhiều câu
hỏi đấy sẽ thuộc về
à chỉ trả lời đâu Chính xác là như nào
nhỉ Đợi tôi một tí Đợi tôi một
thôi đúng không nhỉ À đâu một sinh viên
chọn nhiều đáp án mỗi đáp án chọn bởi
nhiều sinh viên đúng rồi nó vẫn còn
nhiều
nhiều Ok nó vẫn là nhiều
nhiều đúng nhở một sinh viên chọn một
đáp án tại một thời
vẽ database
đi mình
student này answer
này thì mình sẽ có student à đâu
answerer student hoặc student
dấu là sinh viên đã chọn đáp án nào
chước em thế này đáp án
nhá đáp án nà hay anh để đáp án nà trả
dịch ra answer trả lời nó hơi chung
chung nhỉ bảng đáp án Tiếng Anh là
ID answer này
này
này nó mới chuẩn ấy và từ từ cái ID
answer này này mình sẽ nối được biết
được là nó thuộc câu hỏi nào xong rồi
thuộc kỳ thi nào à thuộc bài thi nào
xong rồi thuộc kỳ thi nào đúng thằng
thằng sinh viên này tuy là nó tham gia
kỳ thi
tham gia kỳ thi nhưng mà thông qua cái
những cái đáp án này còn nếu mà em muốn
đánh dấu sinh viên này đã tham gia kỳ
thi này kể cả cho dù nó đã trả lời đáp
án hay chưa thì đúng là mình sẽ phải nối
thằng này với thằng này đấy đây nhá Ừ để
menu many to many nhá em Em hiểu đoạn
này không Em hiểu anh Vừ nói gì không để
em đánh dấu sinh viên này đã tham gia kỳ
thi này à Chính xác là đã làm bài bài
thi này không quan tâm việc nó có trả
lời đáp án hay chưa thì rõ ràng là đây
là một quan hệ nhiều nhiều còn nếu mà em
chỉ quan tâm đến việc là sinh viên này
đã trả lời thì mới tích thì rõ ràng là
nó nối đến cái này mới đúng đúng không
Bởi vì rõ ràng là từ câu hỏi từ từ t cái
đáp án ấy là em biết được sinh viên đấy
đã đã kiểu tham gia kỳ thi này rồi đúng
không đã trả lời câu hỏi và đã tham gia
cái bài thi này rồi Đúng chưa đấy thì rõ
ràng đây là một quan hệ kiểu như này còn
thực ra là sinh viên đã ch sinh viên
đánh dấu vào câu hỏi câu hỏi thực ra hơi
vô nghĩa vì rõ ràng là chẳng cầ từ Đáp
án thì biết sinh viên đấy đã trả lời câu
hỏi đấy Hay chưa mà đúng không
đấy còn việc là để tính điểm thì D thôi
Đó là bài thi này nó sẽ ví dụ trên thang
điểm 10 đúng không trên thang đểm 10 thì
thì cứ lấy 10 chia cho số câu hỏi đúng
không Xong rồi xong rồi cộng với những
cái đáp án đúng à đáp án được cho đến
correct đúng không Mình đếm tổng lại thì
nó sẽ kiểu nói chung là sẽ ra thôi đúng
không sẽ ra được điểm thôi Cái này anh
nghĩ là cái này liên quan câu truy vấn
của bạn nếu mà về sau khó thì anh sẽ hỗ
trợ đâ còn về thiết kế tabas Anh nghĩ là
nó chỉ dng mức này không biết là em
thiết kế như nào nhỉ Xem exel đấy cũng
tham ra kỳ thi này lưu lại này quty là
số lần à số lượng à số lượng không hiểu
số lượng
cố định luôn là một cái câu hỏi có bốn
đáp án rồi cũng là một cách Nhưng mà
theo anh thì theo anh thì cái chính vì
em kiểu chia chia như này này chia chia
như này nhá x xong rồi kết hợp việc
là nói chung là còn đáp án kiểu kiểu như
này em truy vấn Mọi thứ rất khó còn em
thiết kế databas kiểu chuẩn như này nhá
em truy vấn kiểu Em chỉ cần kiểm tra đấy
em lấy ra số số câu số câu hỏi đúng
không
Đấy em lấy được ví dụ 10 câu hỏi đi đúng
không Thì rõ ràng là 10 10 điểm chia cho
10 câu hỏi thì mỗi câu sẽ một điểm đúng
không xong Em đểm xong rồi em đếm xem
những cái câu mà thằng này trả lời đúng
đúng không Thì thì sẽ lấy ra
từ bảng bài thi đã biết bài thi của ai
rồi thì bảng đáp án có ID sinh viên
chẳng để làm
gì
bảng bài thi nối nối như này thì biết
được là sinh viên đấy
sinh viên đấy
a à Đâu Đâu Đâu đúng đúng đúng bạn ấy
nói có nhắc một cái ý đúng đúng đúng
đúng đúng đúng
rồi đúng đúng rồi cái đoạn đ đúng đấy Ờ
bình tĩnh Nếu thấy nối kiểu như này
không hợp lý đâu chuẩn nó sẽ phải như
này này nên là tôi sẽ thường ấy Tôi
thường có vẽ thôi vẽ một cách phát Thảo
thôi cái cái cái đoạn nào đâ nhỉ h bạn
nói cái ý đúng cho dù là cái A có ý đúng
rồi không phải đúng hoàn toàn để tôi thử
nói theo cái góc của tôi hiểu nhá xem
mấy ông có hiểu không
th à Tôi cũng không Tôi thiết kế cái này
gọi là mức tương đối rồi Tôi nghĩ là có
khi tôi cũng chưa thiết kế gọi là chuẩn
lắm đâu về về cái S D thể này nhá Còn về
database thì tôi nghĩa là gọi như
là là rất khó để mà nói hẳn một cái
database Thế nào là chuẩn đôi khi là nó
database phù hợp thôi không có một cái
database nào thực sự là chuẩn cả kể cả
cho dù bạn thiết kế thế nào thực tế nó
sẽ khác đi một tí đây tôi sẽ thường hay
có một cái kiểu như này
này đây chuẩn là như
đợi đợi đợi tô một tí một bài thi này
một sinh viên đây xem xem lại một
tí Ở đây có nói là một sinh viên có thể
thi được làm bài thi đấy nhiều lần không
nhỉ Chắc là không đâu bởi vì thấy là
hiển thị ra cả đáp án đúng Chắc là một
bài thi Sinh viên chỉ làm một lần thôi
mà đúng không thì đây là nó là một nhiều
đúng không một sinh viên một bài thi có
thể làm đ nhiều sinh viên nhưng mà một
sinh viên chỉ làm một lần bài thi đấy nà
xem như
bởi vì là như bạn ấy nói đó là bài thi
của sinh viên đấy thì rõ ràng lưu lại từ
từ Cái đấy phải không hẳn là từ cái đấy
Phả biết đáp án chính xác là đáp án
Đáp án lần đấy sinh viên đấy làm là phải
thuộc cái thằng gọi như
nào chẳng biết giải thích thế nào ngoài
bây giờ vẽ database ch các bạn sẽ dễ
hình dung
hơn cứ cứ hình dung nhá có một bảng bảng
chưa biết là tên là gì nhá Nó sẽ lưu lại
ID của sinh viên này ID student này lưu
lại ID của exel này đấy
chưa biết là tên cái bảng này gì nhá Đấy
Ok là biết được là ví dụ là dat thời
thời gian mà sinh viên đấy làm bài thi
đấy đúng không xong rồi Đương nhiên bảng
này sẽ thêm cột ID nữa
và và sẽ có bảng con của bảng này nữa
bảng này ĐT tên ABC đi sẽ có bảng con
của bảng nữa sẽ lưu lại chính cái ID của
ABC này và ID của answer như
này
đó thì biết được là trong cái bài thi
lần đấy lần đấy của thằng sinh viên đấy
làm nó đã chọn những đáp án nào Đấy nó
như thế còn nếu mà vừa rồi mà mình lưu
cái lưu cái bảng answer
answer student vừa rồi ấy đấy
ID student ID
như này đúng
không và ID student đúng không như này
này thì nếu mà mình có một bảng kiểu như
này giống như vừa nãy là thay vì cả hai
hai bảng nối với nhau như này thì mình
không hề biết được là lần đấy sinh cái
ông đấy thi cái bài thi đấy Tuy là có
thể là đương nhiên là kiểu mình vẫn móc
nối từ cái này có thể nối được ra cái
bài thi thôi nhưng mà nó không hợp lý
lắm Vì rõ ràng là rõ ràng là phải có cái
ông này làm bài thi đấy đã đúng không
Thì mới có đáp án lưu lại cái buổi thi
lần đấy Đúng không ông không hiểu gì tôi
không đấy Nên là sẽ phải có cái thằng
này S từ thằng ấy có thằng này C tôi là
không biết vẽ cái thực thể đ như
nào thật sự như thế Tôi đang không biết
vẽ cái đoạn thực thể này như nào sao cho
nó dễ hiểu dễ hợp lý nhưng mà tôi tôi
hình dung được database nó sẽ kiểu như
này và bảng này sẽ là bảng lưa gì nhỉ
Xem cá ra tên nha bảng lưu em em hiểu
đoạn này không nhỉ bảng
lưu
việc sinh viên
xem student nó
nhanh dễ Sao không nghĩ ra ex student
này một cái đấy và đây Nếu thế thì cái
này sẽ
là exem answer à Tên là gì
tin mà À gì Đáp án mà sinh viên đã chọn
cho bài thi đó thì đặt tên bảng trúng
gian
priv
này
giữa xh à này là gì
nối exem
tên dài cũng được mà
này tên dài
đi
Đấy chữ khó tên kiểu này chữ answer ex
student cũng đúng mà nghe nó cũng Xuôi
xuôi nhỉ Không biết mấy ông đấy xuôi
không ex student answer answer ex
student V sao loạn ngôn đ
không
answer exm student Ok cũng
được đấy anh không biết vẽ thực thể nào
sao cho hợp lý lm ạ Cái đoạn này anh
chịu Để xem thầy cô trên trường Em có
thể vẽ như th nào Ờ nh đại khái Thì bởi
vì nói chung là anh làm thực tế thì bọn
anh không có vẽ thực thể nhiều lắm đâu
thường kiểu hình dung kiểu mình hình
dung ở database mình cần lưu lại những
cái gì các thứ thứ cái nào nên tách ra
cái nào nên gộp lại đôi khi là mình lưu
lại hết trong một bảng để mình đỡ phải
cho cũng là một cách Nhưng mà cái này
nên là chuẩn thì nếu mà làm kiểu bài tập
trên trường thì đương nhiên là chuẩn hóa
thì nên là kiểu như này xem nhá Đợi đợi
tí nhá
chong vẻ đúng đúng đấy tôi thấy đúng
không biết mấy ông thấy thế nào tôi thấy
đúng đúng đấy
th đây nhá đầu tiên là là có sinh viên
đúng không sinh viên thì đương nhiên là
có đây Quay bên này sinh viên đi đăng ký
làm bài thì đương nhiên sin Giả sử Trong
trường hợp mà một cái bài đấy chỉ có một
sinh viên làm đương nhiên là trong
trường hợp kiểu làm kiểu này nhá Nếu mà
làm kiểu này Thực ra riêng cái đề đấy là
sinh viên làm bao nhiêu lần được nếu mà
vẽ theo kiểu như
này nên tôi đang không biết được Tôi
đang vẽ có đúng hay không cơ một toàn bộ
đng này chỉ làm làm bởi nhiều sinh viên
nhưng một sinh viên chỉ thuộc một cái
này rõ ràng là sinh viên để lưu ID Thằng
này nó mới nó mới hợp lý nhưng mà mình
vẽ nhưng mà đương nhiên là không làm
kiểu như thế
à đâu Đây là chính xác là không phải 1 n
đâu mà là phải không có thể 1 hoặc không
ấy Nó là optional
nếu mà mình giả sử mình vẽ 1 n như vừa
rồi là sinh viên chắc chắn làm bài thi
đấy thì tức là sinh viên phải lưu lại
cái ID của bài thi đấy cơ Còn nếu mà vẽ
kiểu này là một sin
viên có thể là không cần làm bài thi đấy
hoặc Nếu mà có thì nó sẽ là một nhiều
hay gì gì đó đấy thì nó sẽ vẽ kiểu này
hình như thế Đang hình dung nó là như
Thế thì mình không cần lưu ID của ID của
sinh viên vào trong cái này mà mình tạo
bảng trung gian như này đấy ừ tôi thấy
đang hợp hợp hợp lý dần dần đấy ok đấy
có bài thi này từ bài thi đấy Mình sẽ
lưu lại được từng đáp án không sao em vẽ
được database như này thì cái về sau về
sau khi mà em truy vấn để lấy ra được
đáp án đúng ấy nó sẽ
đặt tên XM schedule cho bảng có lưu đ
được không
anh Anh chưa hiểu ý em
lắm lịch thi á Ý em là lịch thi
lịch thi đúng không Chị K mì thi thôi
cũng không thể biết được hôm nào bắt đầu
kiểu làm cái bài thi đấy bài thi này
chắc cứ tạo ra trước sau đó thì mình kỳ
thi đấy kiểu ví dụ Giả sử Cái này có
kiểu thời gian thi này đúng không đại
khái thế Ơ sao không bấm được
này này thì thả bị sao
ấy hình như là tôi tôi tôi nhớ Hình như
có Cái Bấc đoạn này
kiểu kiểu gọi nh nào nhỉ Ơ
này đấy giống như thằng này vừa rồi tôi
lỡ xóa rồi không sửa
em vẽ được cái này cũng được có gì thì
anh em chia sẻ lên discord server
discord rồi anh em cùng thảo luận các th
thứ nó hợp lý mà lên lên lên đây vẽ anh
anh không khẳng định anh đúng đâu vì anh
không giỏi vẽ cái này lắm nhưng mà anh
nghĩ là ít ít nhất là database thiết kế
theo kiểu như này cũng tương đối này về
sau nếu mà có vấn đề gì đó thì mình sửa
đúng không Nhưng mà anh anh nghĩa là
kiểu mình mình như này chắc chắn mình sẽ
truy vấn được khá là chuẩn nó sẽ chuẩn
hơn so với
hả ha
sao
ờ cái gì nhỉ Mình thiết kế database nó
sẽ nó sẽ chuẩn hơn so với cái này chắc
chắn anh nhớ thời gian đầu Hồi trước anh
cũng từng làm kiểu như này cơ
Ờ đoạn đoạn này bạn Long k hiểu chưa nhỉ
long đúng không Ừ đúng rồi cũng tên
giống tên
mình có database kiểu kiểu kiểu như này
này thì về sau mình truy vấn các thứ thứ
đầu tiên là lấy ra đầu tiên là lấy ra
được là những sinh viên nào đã tham gia
thi nào đúng không tiếp theo là lấy ra
được những đáp án người đấy Xong rồi Ở
đây có kiểm tra xong rồi lại ánh xạ sang
bên này thì biết được xem đáp án đấy
đúng hay sai đấy Vân Vân Ừ anh thấy
trông cũng hợp lý phết mà xóa đ này đi
này
Ừ có gì anh sẽ đây này để anh tạo luôn
cái
A cái ở trên này để mọi người cùng thỏi
luận luôn vui đúng không
À thiết
kế cơ
sở Quan hệ
đi
cho phần
mềm Excel à
kỳ thi à gì đó chẳng
biết xem đi không biết Đư tiếng biết tạo
như này đã
đấy anh tí anh sẽ có gì nhờ bạn Long đấy
bạn đấy đăng
lại hình ảnh xong à đăng lại đây chắc
anh đăng lên
luôn lại cái file pdf để đề bài cho mọi
người cùng xem sau đó thì anh sẽ phải
pdf tôi để ở trong
phải đáp án chứ Cái mà tôi cũng chữa một
cách tương đối lên lên đấy rồi anh em
mình cùng làm đúng không R xem còn những
cái gì nữa yêu câu gì
nữa mới chỉnh sửa chỉnh sửa Xem thông kê
số lượng người dùng tham gia mũi kỳ thi
tỉ lệ hoàn thành điểm trung bình đấy mấy
cái này chắc là vẫn làm được này cũng
không thêm một cái gì cả nhập thông tin
kỳ thi tên K Thi mô tả loại kỳ thi đấy
tự do thời gian cụ thể danh sách câu hỏi
file Excel có format cố định cái này thì
phức tạp hơn một tí Nếu mà chưa làm việc
với excel các thứ hi thị bảng thống kê
tổng hợp các theo kỳ thi
ok thống kê số lân điểm trung bình phân
phối điểm số cái này Thực ra chưa biết
môn học các thứ thứ cũng hơi hạn chế chỉ
biết được là Ừ ông ấy làm được bao nhiêu
lần bài thi C thừ thứ hiện tại nếu mà
database kiểu này còn thiết kế kiểu dạng
là một sinh viên thể làm đi làm lại cái
bài thi được Nên là chắc mình về sau
mình sẽ phải unic Nếu mà giả sử Nếu mà
chuẩn thì mình sẽ phải unic hai cái này
để cho m sinh viên chỉ làm một bài thi
một lần thôi
nữa đấy đại khái mấy cái tính năng chức
năng chính nó sẽ thiết kế từ datab như
này ok ừ thế thôi Em còn tham MT gì
không
như nào ạ quản lý á mà như này ồ theo
kiểu là mình mình có thể thêm status á
Hay là là nh Anh chưa hình dung được ý
em lắm Hay là mỗi status nên như thế nào
đồ án này của năm mấy vậy ông à Tôi nghĩ
ở đây sẽ thường là năm cuối khi mà nó có
cả liên quan đến cả code với cả thiết kế
một năm cuối hay là kiểu cũng đang học
đồ án kiểu gần cuối Ừ có gì em cứ hỏi
vào đây nhá
Ừ ok ờ
câu hỏi có vẻ chưa có bạn nào hỏi gì
cả tranh thủ lúc đấy
Facebook tôi vẫn đang bị khóa kiểu Chứ
thường Bây giờ tôi đang định tôi đang
định là tôi sẽ kiểu nói chung là những
cái video mà tôi định kiểu chia sẻ tâm
sự mấy ông này thì thưng tôi không định
à kiểu
mở lên để mấy ông xem bởi vì mấy ông cần
thực sự là cần xem không xem hẳn chim
nghiệm một tí chứ không phải
là Xem lướt nên là thành ra là tôi sẽ
muốn đăng ở đâu đó ví dụ là một một là
tôi đang định là à Tôi sẽ chia sẻ kênh
kênh tiktok của mình à Để xong rồi Tôi
thường ngy đăng lại mấy cái video chia
sẻ lại video ấy không phải đăng lại đâu
thì sẽ mấy không thể theo dõi trên đấy
nhưng mà kênh tiktok cá nhân của tôi gi
Trẻ trâu quá thế nên là chắc là chắc là
sẽ à Thực ra tôi có tạo kênh tiktok
riêng của của tôi rồi Ừ chắc tôi sẽ chia
sẻ lên đấy đấy Nói chung là đánh mọi nền
tảng đúng không Nhưng mà nền tảng kia là
nền tảng kiểu chỉ muốn chia sẻ lại thôi
chứ không phải là cái gớm
đấy còn gì nhỉ À còn việc à
cái này Thực ra tôi thường an nói mấy
ông này đó là mình à mình nên đầu tiên
mình phải nên đánh dấu lại mọi thứ mọi
thứ của bản thân hiện tại vân vân như
nào Mục tiêu tương lai như nào mình cứ
thử cứ cứ phải chịu khó đặt bút xuống
viết hoặc là hồi trước tôi từng đang
stus cái gì đó mọi người có cười r mọi
người kiểu chơ B các thứ thế là mình về
sau mình cũng sẽ quên ấy nhưng mà ý là
mình đã từng nghĩ đến nó rồi tôi cảm
thấy là à não mình nó cứ kiểu não con
người mình nó cứ kiểu nó rất là xịn ấy
đó là đỗi khi ông từng nghe một cái gì
ông từng nghĩ đến điều đấy rồi
ấ dần dần ông sẽ làm nó não ông sẽ dần
dần tự làm nó có thể ông không chính xác
ông như không nhớ nó lắm đâu nhưng mà
não Ông vẫn sẽ kiểu kiểu dạng là theo
thói quen không phải thói quen đâ nó là
gì vô thức vô thức ông sẽ làm nó đấy làm
nó trong vô thức luôn và dần dần củng cố
niềm tin tự nhiên là nó na ná giống như
kiểu Tôi nói ông về một cái chủ đề nào
đó lần đầu ông sẽ thấy bỡ ngỡ lần đầu
ông sẽ cảm thấy kiểu bị sốc luôn ấy
nhưng mà xong rồi về sau cũng sẽ kiểu
ngấm dần nó ấy ông cảm thấy là ừ nó
chẳng có gì ghê gớm chẳng có gì quá t
tát nữa nó na ná giống hơi thao túng bản
thân một tí Tôi thường ngay thao Tùng
sinh viên tôi hồi trước hơi dùng từ thao
tụng hơi quá Nhưng mà đúng là nó thế
thật nó gọi là gì nh ám thị à kiểu thế
đó hồi trước tôi dạy sinh viên năm hai
ài dạy lúc đấy dạy chuyên ngành rồi và
cuối năm hai thường sinh viên trường
nghề của tôi đi thực tập thì ngay từ đầu
năm rồi Tôi đã ngày nào cũng bảo mấy em
Đấy ra là về sau sẽ đi thực tập rồi sẽ
công việc Vân Vân Vân Như nào đấy Lúc
đầu thì đứa nào cũng kiểu Uầy đi thực
tập các thứ các thứ khó Vân Vân à mà
ngại đi các thứ các thứ sao rồi về sau
kiểu quen ấy rồi về sau các bạn ấy đi
được tập thật và cảm thấy nó không gì
ghê gớm cả từ việc phòng vấn hay đi là C
thử thử nó cảm thấy tao bị dọa cả năm
rồi th ra vây tao không sợ nữa kiểu kiểu
mình sẽ Nếu mà về sau em có thay đổi
thì có nhiều cách một là cách Bây giờ
anh thường ha làm ở công ty anh sẽ tạo
i5 cho nó mà thể lưu dạng chữ hoặc số
thì tùy Bây giờ Bây giờ trong database
thì nó cũng có kiểu lưu dạng i5 rồi lưu
lại số thì đôi khi mình không khó nhớ về
lúc mình đang xem DB ấy thì mình lại
phải ngồi check lại trong code nên lưu
lại dạng i5 thì nó có cái lợi hơn là như
thế còn về tốc độ ấy thì anh từng thấy
là thực ra anh từng So sánh khá nhiều
với MQ nhá MQ thì anh thấy là nó không
khác biệt lắm về bộ nhớ thì anh không
tìm hiểu cái đấy lắm vì anh thự ra anh
quan tâm về tốc độ hơn nhưng anh nghĩ là
chắc chắn là lưu về số chắc chắn là nó
vẫn tốt nhất so với lưu i5 kể cả nó là
i5 có ít ký tự các thừ
mình nhập
nhỉ Thực ra là để mình nhập thì không
nên lắm phải chính xác mình nhập kiểu gì
mình sẽ dễ bị trùng bài toán ở đây nó
là nó lại phải hỏi là
kiểu để tiện ch người dùng hay để bảo
mật Nếu bảo mật thì đương nhiên là vẫn
để để người dùng nhập Còn nếu Phả tiện
thì nó cứ đầy tự động tăng thôi Như tự
động tăng thì nó cũng sẽ có rất nhiều
bài toán
à về sau phức tạp khác ví dụ
là ví dụ là có nhiều người khó chịu đơn
giản kiểu ID nó cứ kiểu
bị kiểu có lỡ xóa dữ liệu thì nó sẽ kiểu
bị cách nh một đoạn này đấy hoặc là hoặc
là kiểu à hacker có thể đoán được từ ID
thể đoán được xem mình có lượng bao
nhiêu người dùng nên ra cái đấy không
hẳn quan trọng lắm đại khái người khác
dễ đoán được ID đ đấy còn gì nhở n cả là
việc để database tự động tăng thì nếu mà
em tách nó ra th nhiều database con thì
nó sẽ nó sẽ mỗi con nó tự động tăng nó
sẽ càng sai nên là nói chung là cái này
phải cái này phải là theo nhu cầu của em
muốn
Nói chung là thiết kế Mọi thứ là về sau
thiết kế đ B mọi thứ đều có lý do nó cả
mình mình mình càng học sâu mình càng
kiểu
biết mình càng kiểu càng biết kiểu trải
nhiệm nhiều ấy đấy thì mình càng biết
thêm có rất nhiều lý do để mình làm điều
này và không và né được kia hay là làm
điều này chấp nhận rủi ro này làm điều
kia chấp nhận rủi ro kia đấy Nói chung
là thiết kế ra B cài tôi càng thấy phía
sau nó càng hay càng cuốn kiểu kiểu như
thế có lý do nó
cảm thực ra hồi trước tôi bị nhạy cảm cả
từ nhục
à ta nói rồi thì miếng miếng ăn là miếng
nhục thì kiểu Nếu nó rộng hơn thì nó sẽ
là kiểu mình khi mình mang nợ một ai đó
đúng không Thì mình nói chung là sẽ rất
là bị bị
kiểu gọi như nào nhỉ ông sẽ nói chung là
ông đầu tiên ông sẽ rất là ngại với
người đấy đã x rồi đi khi phi xong người
ta kiểu nói mấy cái gì gì đó ví dụ tôi
một Điền hình đi cơ cơ thôi lấy minh
chứng bản thân mình vậy thì dụ Giả sử
à Các bác cho mình một cái gì đó này
chẳng hạn rồi thành ra đương nhiên là
mình phải tôn trọng người lớn tuổi thôi
và nó các bác mình nữa nhưng không có
nghĩa là kiểu dạng là các bác muốn nói
mọi thứ về mình đều được đúng không ạ
đúng không Nhưng mà Bởi vì kiểu Các bác
cho mình các thứ thứ rồi à đặc biệt đấy
hồi bé nữa nên thành ra không Không kiểu
dạng
là không thể trả được đúng không các bác
cho ti để giúp đỡ các th các thứ xong
rồi đươ nhiên hô bé h ta kiếm được tiền
trả lại hay gì gì đó đấy nên thành ra là
kiểu mình phải chấp nhận chịu đựng đấy
đấy ý ý tôi như thế đấy Đấy là một đấy
là một nhá cái thứ hai tại sao tự nhiên
tôi lại ghi lại cái điều này và cái thứ
hai mình ăn mế nhục nó là đôi khi mình
ăn ấy Ví dụ là xo mình kiểu trâu trâu
buộc kết trâu ăn à câu ấy đúng nhỉ thỉnh
thoảng lôi ca g tục ngữ th bây giờ mình
rốt băn thỉnh thoảng nhắc ca g tục ngữ
hay là danh ngôn gì đó mình sợ mình nhắc
sai Ừ chắc là đúng đấy
thì thì khi mà mình ăn trước mặt một
người nào đó mà không được ăn hoặ chẻ
giả là họ họ không ăn tại thời điểm đấy
đấy
nhiều người thích thế cơ nhiều người gọi
là Tao thích được sướng trước người khác
bất hạnh tôi tôi không như thế tôi kiểu
không thích kiểu mình ví dụ ví dụ điển
hình trong giờ làm việc chẳng hạn tự như
mình đói mình đang rất đói nhưng mà mình
cũng không muốn kiểu ngồi ăn trước mặt
mọi người cùng nhìn mình nó không hay
kiểu thế nên
là nên là đối tôi gọi là mình được may
mắn hơn người khác thế nó cũng là một
cái phần trách nhiệm nào đó trách nhiệm
Vô Hình nào đó là mình cảm thấy mình
phải trân trọng một cái điều đấy Và mình
phải gọi như nào Đấy mình phải thể hiện
mình xứng đáng với những điều đấy ví dụ
điển hình thôi đó là rất nhiều lúc tôi
cảm thấy tôi may
mắn May mắn
hơn Cứ cho may mắn hơn so quá khứ hoặc
may mắn hơn khá nhiều người ít nhất là
bây giờ đang có mạng để ngồi nói cho mấy
ông nghe chẳng hạn đấy C th thứ có nhiều
người đang không được như thế nhiều
người đang phải lo nghĩ rất nhiều thứ
vấn đề khác tôi cảm thấy mình vừa may
mắn như đi kèm với trách nhiệm bởi vì
mình đang tận hưởng những cái thứ mà
người khác đang khó có được nên là mình
sẽ phải có trách nhiệm hơn xã hội này
các thứ thứ Ôi nghe cái đấy nghe ngầu
nhỉ Nghe kiểu đạo lý rồi Kiểu biển Vông
các thử Thô nhưng mà nhiều lúc tôi nghĩ
thế thật thế nên là tôi mới muốn kiểu
chia sẻ may mắn hay là muốn kiểu có thể
làm được một cái gì
đó nhưng mà Nhưng mà mình gọi là tôi làm
là theo cái sức của mình thôi và gọi là
mình cũng tham gia một vài cái tình
nguyện như vài cái gọi là tình nguyện
Nhưng mà phải những cái mà mình làm được
và mình thích làm đấy cũng không hẳn là
tình nguyện lắm gọi là như này ví dụ mấy
cái nói chung là đại khái là mình làm
cái tốt theo cái lương Tâm lòng tốt của
mình thì cũng đúng Nhưng mà nó phù hợp
với cái sở thích và nh và cái năng lực
của mình chứ không phải là
gọi là như nào
nhỉ mình vượt qua bản thân mình để làm
những cái điều tình nguyện
khác tôi nói thấy có Văn vở quá khó hiểu
quá không nhỉ ví dụ nhá Tôi tôi thể đóng
góp được m tiền Ok tôi
đóng Tôi có thể Gần đây tôi có tham gia
đi làm tình nguyện phiên làm quản trò
cho trẻ các trẻ em hoàn cảnh khó khăn Ok
cái đấy phù hợp tôi làm à Tôi không cảm
thấy tôi phù hợp việc thanh niên tình
nguyện để mà đi làm một cái việc lao
động kiểu trên tay kiểu lên núi lên Bạc
hay cái gì gì đó Ok tôi không làm và nó
nói thằng không có th không có thời gian
một phần nói chung không thích cái đấy
lắm không phải không thích làm những
hành động đấy mà nó là như nào Tôi cảm
thấy là tôi có thể đem lại được nhiều
giá trị bằng một cách khác đấy Đấy đấy
là những cái mà gọi là mình chỉ làm tình
nguyện những cái mình thích còn những
cái mình không thích mình không làm đấy
nhưng mà gọi
nh tự nhiên đang từ miếng ăn miếng nhục
nó dẽ hơi nhiều
hướng Tôi vẫn đang chỉ chia sẻ góc nhìn
của tôi nhá Nếu mà Mấy ông thấy thẩn cận
quá thì mấy ông thể C
ý tiếp theo ôi nãy ông nãy giờ mấy ông
kia đang bàn về cái gì đ ban về
id id cha thì sinh có quy luật gì không
ạ Nếu thế nếu mà để tự sinh trong thì
nên tự sinh trong code chứ database nó
không hỗ
trợ thực ra database có hỗ trợ Nếu mà em
dùng cher hay dùng gì đó Nhưng mà thường
là không ai làm thế cả mình nếu mà có
thể giống kiểu công ty tôi này kiểu tự
sinh ra uid ấ lưu trong
phải xóa hết được dữ liệu bảng nhiều mới
xóa được thằng một tránh bị lỗi thì mới
nên dùng nhì nhỉ giải pháp dùng shop
Delete Có ai có cách khác không chỉ đơn
giản là nếu mà tốt nhất ấy đó là em
không nên đánh ph
key f key nó Nó là một cái dàng
đâu Không sót
Ý em làm sao không Đương nhiên là không
xóa được thằng cha khi mà có thằng con ý
em mà Xóa Thằng con bay thằng tra hay
như nào nhỉ À đâu nhỉ Không xóa được
đúng không
ạ Ờ để tôi nói lại nhá Không xóa được
thằng cha khi mà có thằng con thì em mà
xóa Thằng cha thì bay luôn con đúng
không Hay như
cái chủ đề xóa khác thì còn cái về việc
là quy luật kiểu giáng buộc thì nó lại
khác
nữa Nhưng mà chuẩn thì thì tôi thường
hay thấy là cũng dần dần về sau hạn chế
không dùng font key kiểu nó liên quan
việc dòng bộ quá thì cái việc lúc mày
Insert update thì nói chung là để chắc
chắn về mặt dữ liệu code thôi chứ không
cần phải khắt khe quá về forki
hai
thì nói chung là cái này nó chia sẻ hơi
mang tính cá nhân một tí không biết nói
chung là mấy ông tôi đ nói về vấn đề này
nó hơi mặt đen tối một tí
hơi tế nhị một tí cũng có Nói chung là
tiêu cực chắc chắn có bởi vì hồi đấy trẻ
người non Dạ Nói chung là không biết tôi
nghĩ là có thể mấy ông có thể có thể mấy
ông từng Ui tôi nói cái này ra không
biết YouTube đánh gậy gì Ông đó là mấy
ông từ nghĩ việc
à kết thúc Kết thúc cuộc sống của mình
không biết là mấy cũng từng nghĩ thế
chưa Tôi chắc chắn là tôi hồi trước rồi
tôi t từng nghĩ đến điều đấy nhưng mà
hồi cấp hai tôi không nghĩ đến điều đấy
hồi cấp hai thì tôi lại nghĩ việc là nói
chung là hồi đấy Kiểu à gia đình kiểu Tạ
áp lực các thứ thứ và chính bản thân
mình áp lực nhiều cái kiểu hồi không có
bạn bè không bạn về thần thiết gì cả nên
là thành À đấy Nói chung Chẳng cảm thấy
chẳng ai hiểu mình vân vân xong rồi chán
nản học hồi đây cũng bình thường nên là
Hồi đấy tôi đã n nghĩ nó nó chung là có
hai cái quyết định à Hai thi nhỉ hai lựa
chọn Một là chấp nhận tiếp tục cuộc sống
đấy để mà và gọi là cố gắng học và hy
vọng một ngày nào đó mình sẽ có thể ít
nhất là thoát ra khỏi cái nhà thoát khỏi
mọi thứ ĩ ra là mình không bị dòng không
bị bị phải phải kiểu dạng là bố mẹ còn
nuôi mình hay là mọi người nói chung là
tôi nói miếng ăn mế nhục kia có lý do mà
nghĩ â chưa mình bị áp lực bởi vì cái
chữ Hiếu rất nhiều cái làm cho mình
không có tiếng nói vân vân mình không
được quyết định một cái gì cả Nói chung
cuộc sống nó áp lực
đấy thì mình chỉ biết cố gắng học các
thứ thứ thì Hy vọng là cuộc đời này nó
sẽ sang một cái trang nào đó hai là lúc
đấy mình bỏ nhà đi bụi đấy Hồi đấy tôi
đã nghĩ là có hai cái lựa chọn như
thế thì à Nếu mà Mấy ông thấy tôi vẫn
còn ở đây Bây giờ thì đúng mấy ông biết
tôi chọn gì rồi tôi đã chọn cái một
không biết được cho nó có phải hèn nhát
hay cái gì Không nhưng mà hồi đấy Đúng
là tôi nghĩ là kiểu Thôi mình cứ cắm đầu
vào làm một cái gì gì đó và hiy vọng là
chỉ có hy vọng thôi và có niềm tin là
mình sẽ thay đổi được cái cuộc sống hiện
tại đấy ết nhân là bây giờ nó Khá hơn
Khá nhiều rồi Mình cảm thấy bớt áp lực
hơn các thứ thoải m
Nhiều người bảo là nó là thoải mái trong
tư tưởng và cả trong tài trình vân vân
nữa để mình không bị không bị kiểu bây
giờ không ai có thể nói được mình theo
kiểu là vì vì tao nuôi máy hay vân vân
nó chong hố trước bị bị kiểu áp lực rất
nhiều cái kiểu như
thế Tôi biết là có có một vài người ở
đây cũng có thể bị kiểu áp lực kiểu như
thếo kiểu là vì chữ hiếu vì rất nhiều ý
tố khiến cho mình không thể tự do quyết
định được một cái gì đó luôn phải cân
nhắc mọi thứ thứ C áp lực thì ai cũng có
ra thì nó
còn có lựa chọn nhiều người Hồi trước
chỉ tôi Tôi biết có một vài người là
đường cùng luôn ấy chỉ có một đường đi
thôi Tôi muốn chia sẻ cái này để mà nói
các bạn kiểu có bạn nào mà cũng đã từng
kiểu cùng đường như tôi
thì tôi cảm thấy hồi đấy đường cùng đấy
nó là tôi bị áp lực nhiều
lắm
thì cứ cố gắng tiếp thôi và chắc chắn là
nó sẽ có cố gắng thì nó mới gọi là gọi
là nh thì mới có thay đổi chứ nếu mà
mình cứ cứ
kiểu buông xuôi hay gì đó thì chắc chắn
nó sẽ chẳng thay đổi gì cả
đúng không
có việc IT phần mền trên Hà Nội Tần tin
Thuyên
nhà đấy có rất nhiều người đang bị kiểu
C má các tiền các thờ thớ bây giờ Kể cả
không phải it ngày nào cũng kiểu dạng là
kiểu có vấn đề cả đúng không các bạn
thực ra là các bạn cũng không cần phải
chăm chăm cứ cố kiếm công việc it làm gì
cả tôi quen rất nhiều người là kiểu dần
dần về sau gọi là như là hồi trước tôi
có nghe anh Độ hay là anh bom men từng
chia sẻ gì phải các bạn bây giờ đôi khi
hơi bị cái tôi
quá không nói cụ thể bạn nhá Nhưng mà
đang nói là chung chung là là ví dụ là
mình học xong nề it chẳng hạn nghĩ rằng
là mình học xong it r mình phải đi làm
IT mình không làm ngành ngành ng khác
các thứ thứ vân vân mãi về sau khi mình
hạ được cái tôi mình rồi mình m bắt đầu
đi làm nhng cái Ngà nghề khác để ít nhất
phải đấy kiếm cái gì cho mồm đã Vân Vân
Đấy xong rồi trong thời gian đấy mình
mới Mình có thể học thêm các thứ thứ vẫn
chị khó ngồi các nghiên cứu các thứ thứ
cho nên khi mình thực sự kiếm được công
việc phù hợp với mình đấy chứ mình đôi
khi mình học xong cái gì đó Mình cứ nghĩ
là mình phải chăm chăm vào mỗi cái công
việc ấy thôi thành ra là thành ra kiểu
trong khoảng thời gian đấy có nh nhiều
người dậm chân tại chỗ Đúng nghĩa luôn
người đấy cũng không học không tự nghiên
cứu thêm trong ngành nghề nhưng mà cũng
không đi làm cái khác kiểu mình bị ì ra
mình bị kiểu chậm ấy m không hiểu không
Sa lại càng ngồi so sánh mình với bạn bè
đồng lứa là thằng khác may mắn kiếm được
việc rồi các th thử xong rồi cảm thấy
thôi mình thất bại C thứ thử tự nhên
mình bị đuối hơn ấy Hà ông cứ đi làm
nghề khác ông sẽ nhận ra điều là mình
chẳng phù hợp gì ngành nghề này nên là
mình sẽ biết cắm đầu vào học để cắm đầu
và nghiên cứu hơn cái gì gì đó để mà
mình kiếm được công việc phù hợp với
mình hơn đấy nó còn là như thế còn hơn
là mình chỉ nằm một chỗ xong rồi cứ để
thời gian chôi qua thì lúc đấy thì tự
mình đang giết mình thôi nm gì có ai
kiềm kiềm lại mình tự mình đang kiềm lại
mình thôi đúng không ạ
Đấy tự nhiên hôm nay tôi khuyên được mấy
cái câu chim nghiệm phết nhỉ
Anh ơi em chuẩn bị phòng vấn Note re thì
cần chuẩn bị những gì ạ Anh không biết
là mấy cái đây lắm nhưng mà anh nghĩ là
em cứ lên mạng hỏi cho mấy cái đấy Nói
chung là mấy ông học về it mà mấy không
phải chịu khó tra các th
thứ tôi cũng không biết mấy cái đấy Thật
tôi cũng mấy cái hôm đầu đi phỏng vấn
tôi cũng không đi tìm hiểu kỹ giống như
mấy ông hiện tại bây giờ đâu Nên tôi
không biết được cái cái mấy ông phải
trải qua cái gì hay tôi phải trải qua
cái gì Đơi khuyên mấy ông cả hơi tiếc
đấy ok không ai nói gì nữa chắc là tôi
tạm nghỉ Hôm nay đã tôi gọi nhái tranh
thủ gọi là xả cá thằng đ giống như hôm
nay tôi nói thực ra hôm hôm trước tôi
nói là đng hôm nay phải ngồi cốt nhưng
hôm nay cũng thấy hơi choáng hơi nhiều
tâm trạng tì n tôi chỉ chữa bài được cho
bạn xong rồi cũng nghỉ ngơi thôi
hẹn mấy ông vào buổi sau H vọng buổi sau
tôi lấy lại được Facebook rồi thực ra là
nói Nửa vui nửa buồn thế Facebook nó có
nhiều kỷ niệm thôi chứ nói và có nhiều
liên lạc đữ th C này tôi thấy là trên
facebook Gọi
nh nó mang lại cho mình khá nhiều Cảm
Xúc bao gồm cảm xúc tiêu cực ha mọi thứ
cũng có chứ không phải trên đấy toàn thứ
vui vẻ chẳng qua trên đây có rất nhiều
liên lạc kỷ niệm các thứ thứ nữa nên
là vẫn muốn cố níu lại
nó OK Chào mấy ông